at least of academic scientific
scholarly merits so I will just proceed
to ask professor north house of our
University to take the floor I would
like to join the others in welcoming
Nick Stern and as a team to Yale this
Great Hall is Yale's great concert hall
actually and it reminds us that
economics is an art as well as the
science the Stern Review has put forth a
very somber assessment of the risks of
climate change I put one of the more
striking quotations up here for you it
concludes that if we don't act the
overall costs and risks of climate
change will be equivalent to losing at
least five and as much as 20% of GDP or
more the review proposes sharp and
immediate reductions in emissions I
think that was not sufficiently
highlighted today and although it uses
the tools and language of economics its
results are dramatically different
because of this call for immediate
action now what I want to ask is what is
the reasoning behind this radical
revision is it based on sound economic
analysis and what should we conclude
before I do this I'm going to start with
us something a little different I want
to actually start as a survey the
reviewers of the reviews there have been
at least a dozen very careful reviews of
the stern review and I thought what it
might be useful to do is provide a
summary of what I think the areas of
agreement and disagreement or potential
disagreement are this is my own view and
I'm sure that other panelists will
disagree with even this summary of
agreements but I think would be useful
to start with the these now there are
five
positions that I think our areas of
agreement among the stern team and much
of the research in this area economic
and scientific research the first most
important one I think is that global
warming is the state of the art science
it's good science and I'll just show you
one diagram if you just I'll leave this
up here a second a very important
diagram the Keeling curve and if if you
wonder where all this started it
probably started with this curve a
second item of agreement is that
unchecked warming may lead to large and
costly long-run ecological and economic
impacts and here there are lot there
lots of words in that they're all
important unchecked large costly
long-run ecological and economic a third
one which was emphasized in the
presentations this morning is that the
complexities in uncertainties are
enormous in this area in the science to
begin with and perhaps most importantly
I think what was not emphasized this
morning was also the uncertainties in
the ecological impacts broadly speaking
and in the economics as well getting
into the economic side of things I think
there's consensus among the researchers
that global warming is a major what's
called a global public good of
everybody's business and therefore
nobody's business and in a sense and
fifth one which is that solutions will
involve raising the market price of
carbon now I want to pause a minute on
this fifth point because it is a very
important statement in the review and
one that differs from some of the other
discussions in this area the review
emphasizes the need for increasing the
part the price of carbon emissions it
might come through a carbon tax it might
be come through auctions or trades of
marketable emission permits such are not
as are now being traded in the European
Union I just call these carbon taxes
because it's a short word
but the point is it's really a shorthand
for a market penalty or limitation the
important point which the review
stresses and economists as slightly
unpleasant people to begin with always
emphasize is that a carbon tax raising
the cost of carbon and necessary for a
solution it's necessary both to provide
incentives to individual firms and to
households to get them to curb their
emissions and something also that's
probably just as important in the long
run is to stimulate research and
development on low carbon technologies
carbon prices have to be raised to
transmit the social costs of this to the
everyday decisions of billions of firms
and people now this inconvenient
economic truth is virtually absent for
most economic discussions of climate
policy and if you saw Al Gore's
documentary he generally walked up to
this point asked about the costs of
climate change and then he backed away
by saying it was an opportunity and not
a cost but the review emphasizes it must
be faced as a penalty for those who emit
carbon now the second - there are some
major or minor disagreements and these
are in the areas of the trajectories of
emissions and temperature and impacts
and also the central estimates of
climate damages and abatement costs now
what about the underlying description
here I think the critics are divided
maybe the discussants are divided I
don't know but some have been very
critical and some said well it's a
reasonable view of the world my own
personal reading is that on the whole
it's a reasonable interpretation of
existing science I think they do
exaggerate some of the extreme events
and I think they compound some of the
extreme events and it's not clear to me
exactly what if you actually were to
look behind these into the black box of
of the minds of the reviewers or of the
page model
what exactly is going on but I had the
other side of this I think this is
extremely helpful because we know that
there is a tendency among humans and
institutions to underestimate risks and
even more importantly often to for get
about correlated risks but in any case
the differences here are probably in the
tens of percents rather than the
hundreds of percents now in one respect
I would say the review and flicks cruel
unusual punishment on the English
language and in the quote I started with
it said that it finds the cost of
climate change equivalent to a 20% cut
in per capita consumption now and
forever in this frightening statement
suggests that we're about to drive off a
cliff they just walk out here and all of
a sudden that you will find yourself not
in snow but in seawater but actually
when the review says now it doesn't mean
today and so it's a little confusing
in fact these impacts are far in the
future and the calculations in the
review particularly this calculation
depends critically on the assumption of
low goods and time discounting and just
to just to give you some numbers from
the review and that you take their mean
loss case it's 1% of world output in
2050 and 3% of world output in 2100 and
this becomes 20 percent now so again
you've gone somehow from 1% and 3% 2120
spent now because of an extreme
assumption about discounting which I'm
going to talk to about a little bit I
think this is an actually an
exaggeration of about two thousand
percent
yeah but the result is actually not
primarily because of an over essent in
my view of over estimate of damages but
because how they add these all up now
there are two areas where I think the
areas of what I call fundamental
disagreement one is the role of peer
review and modeling and reducibility and
the other is on discounting I will I'm
just going to deal with each of these
the first one a little briefly and then
the other one
spend most of my time on well the the
review is a political document it was
presented here very eloquently by a
distinguished scholar but it's still
it's a political document and advocacy
is its purpose but that is London and
this is Yale and so I want to address it
as a scientific study one of the
complaints I have about it it's is that
it if you go back the central
methodology by which science and here
are include economics as a science
operates is peer review and reducibility
but the study did not play by those
ground rules it was published without a
prior appraisal of methods and
assumptions by independent experts I
couldn't find a document with sources
and meses methods that would allow me to
reproduce the results I couldn't retrack
over their steps now you might say well
this is kind of academic politeness and
but it's not it's really fundamental to
good science and economic analysis in
London as in New Haven these practices
are ones that protect authors from
mistakes they help governments from
digging themselves ever deeper into
their own misguided realities and the
British government is not infallible in
questions of economic and scientific
analysis on global warming any more than
it was on weapons of mass production
five years ago external review and
reproof reproducibility are essential
for ensuring logical reasoning and
appropriate respect for contrary points
of view and I very much wish that
instead of publishing it that it had
gone through an internal review process
and an external review process with an
outside board of scientists and so
natural and social scientists before it
was published the main thing I want to
talk about however today is the
discounting controversy and the second
point here and the main point I want to
make is that virtually the entire
difference between the results in the
review and those in most other studies
lies in its approach to discounting now
at the outset
and Nick Stern talked about that today
and he made very persuasive comments I
thought about discounting but I think we
should just I just want to start with a
quote on person I think is the leading
economist on the analysis of discounting
in economic growth the challenge
Copeland's telling Koopmans was a Nobel
Prize winning economist Yale when he did
this work on discounting and having
spent many years studying it and
particularly studying the issues
involved in low discounting he wrote the
problem of optimal economic growth is
too complicated for one to feel
comfortable making an entirely opry
choice of the time discount rate before
one knows the implications of
alternative choices now this app this
conclusion applies with even even
greater force in global warming models
which are much more complex than the
models Koopmans analyzed I think that
the review simply got tangled up in the
trees of hide theory of discounting and
lost sight of the forest and if Beth is
here he can tell them about the forest
now what are the practical implications
here the practical implications of the
discounting centers on the appropriate
real interest rate to use in making
investments to slow climate change and
buy a real interest rate I mean the
interest rate you use to compare goods
and services over time so goods in the
2100 vs. Goods today or Goods next year
versus Goods today not utilities and
worth wildness of generations in the
future versus today and I note in
passing there are very complicated
issues involved here that we could
discuss but we won't concerning risk
uncertainty the equity premium the risk
structure taxes borrowing constraints
and so on just so that's just for my
scientific colleagues here who are gonna
complain what I'm saying is
oversimplified now the theoretical a per
apparatus in the review leads to very
low real interest rates the equilibrium
real interest rate in them in their view
is 1.4 percent per year over the
indefinite future so when comparing
potential and this is on goods when
comparing potential investments in
climate abatement on the one hand with
those say in education in America and
China vaccines in Europe or Africa
shelter anywhere the stern would
discount the costs and benefits from
climate investments at this very low
rate now my main concern is that this is
a very simple one that having gotten
tangled up in the high theory of
discounting from Koopmans on it then
basically seriously underestimated the
return on investment now maybe not in
Mary England since 1914 but definitely
it underestimated the rate of return in
the United States China and much of the
rest of the world and I'll just provide
one example from James Jim Heckman
a Chicago Nobel prize-winning economist
written and labor economist has
estimated the return on human capital
what else education and he writes quote
the true rate of return to education in
China may be as high as 30 or 40 percent
per year now I'm sure Jeff Sachs could
find a similar large pool of high-yield
investments in health and other
infrastructure investments in Africa and
even the 20-year inflation index super
super super super safe bonds in the
United States have a higher return than
that used by the review so let me just
take a moment to examine what difference
it makes and if you actually if you go
back and read Chris hosts hopes paper
his results are actually minor but
simpler in structure than his but his
are very much the same and he talked
about that this morning so what I what I
did just for this purpose try to
understand for myself what's going on
I drew upon an existing model of the
economics of climate change known as the
dice model
which has been updated to recently
available taste data economics and
science and then I made three runs and
those are described here and if you want
to look at the gory details
they are explained in the National
Bureau of Economic Research working
paper and you can actually be one more
gear with the goriest of details then
you can go to my website so there are
three things I examined one is is that
what I call a kind of standard plain
vanilla a run-of-the-mill climate policy
where you ask what does what does the
optimal time path look like for the path
of greenhouse gas abatement over the
which maximizes this and that and the
other thing over the indefinite future
using us a higher time discounting rate
of one-and-a-half percent but one that
is time tempting to produce market
reproduce market interest rates then the
second one was I just simply put in the
stern parameters the discount rate that
that Nick talked about today the pure
time rate of 0.1 percent and the
elasticity of one that's run two and run
three was okay so I actually am not
religious on this issue of what the time
discount rate is and I accept the point
that it might be very low it might be
0.1 I think zero has got some technical
issues but 0.1 is fine and so but but I
do insist that if you can do that then
you should have a model it actually
tracks you should have a set of
parameters that track what's going on in
the world okay you don't want to have
and have oil prices at ten cents a
barrel you want to have something the
tracks market interest rate so but it's
basically what I did was take the
certain assumption about the discount
rate on time and recalibrate the utility
function to get the market returns so
what are these show okay well I've got
two graphs that give you an idea well
this is the first one I think this shows
my major complaint with the stern the
stern apparatus they don't have a really
a model but it's a it's a model in the
heads of the reviewers and it was the
page model actually used it so you can
see here the top two lines are the
models which
are calibrated to track what I calculate
is world real interest rule real returns
on capital just I say 60 to 7% but I'm
not gonna I can't promise those are
exactly the right numbers but declining
gradually over time as projected
economic growth slows if you look at the
stern numbers the problem is that the
existing estimate of the market return
is way above the equilibrium so what the
model does is saves like mad but the
model tells you to do saves like mad
investment rates go way up so you can
get that interest rate down where it
should be which is near 1% so what this
says is that to me is that the stern
runs are basically inconsistent with the
market returns on capital now I can't
stand here and say I know that my view
is right and the stern view is wrong but
they point to no evidence suggesting
that their view on the return to capital
is right and I think there is
substantial evidence such as what I
quoted from Heckman that they are wrong
now the second slide shows a slightly
different thing related to what we
talked about this morning which is the
vision on the global carbon tax so this
is the social cost of carbon which is
one where the tax rate is set equal to
the social rate the social cost so
they're actually brought together and
what you can see is in the the bottom
show three runs it show the runs one and
three that I mentioned earlier it also
shows another one which is what the
social what the price has to be limit
carbon dioxide concentrations to two
times original co2 so the 555 and then
the one almost off the screen there is
the stern run that's to say the one what
you should do with the carbon tax if you
really believe the point one time
preference and the one percent and the
one person and the one elasticity of one
and the point is that it's basically
asking for much higher carbon taxes and
much higher emissions reductions than
are consistent with market interest
rates so that for those of you who don't
really know this unit of measure - well
just to give you some idea of the
different
is between the runs for us if you take
emissions and carbon tax and multiply
those together you get the total u.s.
carbon tax revenues or costs or transfer
as a distribution around 30 billion
dollars for the mainstream view of in
the $20 a ton and in the 300 billion
dollars per year this is for the stern
carbon tax you get an increase in energy
expenditures that's your electricity
gasoline so on bill of about 3% for the
mainstream models and around 30% for the
stern and you have an increase in
average household energy expenditures in
US households of a little over 2 a
little over 200 for the mainstream and
two and a half thousand for the stern
for the stern parameters now I want to
be clear here about this the main point
is that these are very large numbers we
have to be we have to respect the world
we live in and the politics we live in
and I think actually what happens is if
I were if I were on the stern team and
looked at the implications of my ethical
parameters what I do is have try to
nudge those down a little bit to fit
into reality so let me conclude how much
and how fast the globe reduce its clean
greenhouse gas emissions the Stern
Review answer these questions clearly
and ambit unambiguously we need urgent
sharp and immediate reductions my
conclusion is that the economic
reasoning justifies this over the longer
run but not in the short run that the
economic policy recommendations in terms
of immediate reductions are ones that
are based on an unrealistic view of
discount rates so as I was thinking
about a way to summarize this
I sent Nick an email where I said I
think it's a great study but you're 50
years ahead of their time
in the sense that your carbon tax is 50
years ahead of where it ought to be well
okay so then I was thinking since
everybody else is 50 years behind the
time if you average the two you might
come out just right thank you very much